si les discriminations entre les femmes
et les hommes étaient abolis madame la
ministre la parole est amendable
kosciusko morizet
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre en france en 2016 un
prédicateur peut en toute impunité
encouragé à ne pas fréquenter les
mécréants considérer une femme comme la
moitié d'un homme ou faire croire à des
enfants qui écoutait de la musique les
transformera en cochon
au cours des auditions menées pour
l'examen de ma proposition loi
pénalisant la prédication subversive
nous avons eu la confirmation
que notre droit n'offrait pas tous les
outils pour lutter efficacement contre
les idéologies politico religieuses
radicales de plus en plus dissimulé et
du coup les autorités se trouvent
contraintes à de véritables contorsions
juridiques pour obtenir la fermeture des
mosquées salafistes
jeudi la semaine prochaine nous
débattrons dans cet hémicycle d'une
proposition loi pour mettre hors la loi
les prédicateurs salafistes radicaux co
signée par une cinquantaine de nos
collègues elle a été inscrit à l'ordre
du jour grâce à notre président de
groupe christian jacob que je remercie
notre objectif c'est intervenir plus en
amont du processus de radicalisation
nous voulons offrir aux juges aux élus
locaux aux citoyens une base légale à la
condamnation des prédicateurs qui
promeuvent une ségrégation identitaire
se posent certains voudraient nous
opposer la liberté d'opinion pourtant il
n'est pas question de sanctionner une
opinion qui reste libre mais sa
diffusion et c'est bien différent
d'autres voudraient nous opposer la
liberté religieuse mais on ne peut pas
habillé n'importe quoi de la liberté
religieuse
la liberté de conscience oui la religion
comme prétexte pour saper les principes
de la république non monsieur premise je
vous ai interpellé à ce sujet dans
l'hémicycle en juillet nous en avons
discuté début septembre de façon
constructive
soutiendrez-vous cette démarche jusqu'au
bout pour que nous élaborions ensemble
les voies et les moyens d'améliorer la
sécurité des français merci la parole et
à monsieur jean jacques urvoas garde des
sceaux ministre de la justice
oui monsieur le président madame la
députée il y à l'intention sur laquelle
nous pourrions nous retrouver il ya les
modalités que vous proposez l'intention
vous en avez effectivement fait part
dans cet hémicycle c'était le 20 juillet
me semble-t-il dans une question et vous
avez écrit au premier ce qui vous a reçu
le 1er septembre nous avons évidemment
regardé avec beaucoup d'attention parce
que dans ce domaine personne n'a la
science infuse et on est toujours plus
intelligent quand on analyse avant de
parler et donc à la lecture de votre
proposition de loi nous en concluons
deux éléments soit ce que vous proposez
existe déjà et je vais essayer de le
démontrer soir ce que vous avancez de
nouveau nous paraît trop imprécis pour
ce qu'est ce que ça soit le remède ne
soit pas pire que le mal je m'explique
vous proposer de lutter contre
l'apologie du terrorisme
cela existe déjà c'est l'article 421
tirer 2-5 du code pénal et je vous
indique comme à la représentation
nationale d'ailleurs que l'année
dernière en 2015 il y a eu 3 185
condamnation sur ce motif grâce au texte
qui a été voté par cette assemblée de
manière extrêmement massive et sur le
premier trimestre de cette année nous
avons déjà deux cents dix neuf
condamnations sur l'apologie autorise
qui montre que nous poursuivons quand
nous en avons les moyens juridiques et
que les faits sont avérés vous proposez
où vous souhaitez éviter que les mineurs
soient préservés de messages incitant au
terrorisme c'est possible d'ores et déjà
en vertu de l'article 227-24 du code
pénal vous voulez sanctionner la
provocation directe à commettre un crime
ou un délit c'est quelque chose qui est
prévu par l'article 23 de la loi du 29
juillet 1981 vous évoquez maintenant les
ministres du culte qui dans leurs propos
contesterait les lois ce que vous venez
de dire madame c'est possible en
utilisant l'article 35 de la loi de 1905
la loi de 1905 c'est possible et donc
dans ce domaine je ne sais pas ce qu'est
la prédication subversive permettez moi
de vous citer portalis le fondateur du
code civil en 1805 les lois inutiles
affaiblissent les lois net